What? 50% of Hassan's content is just getting one guide and pulling
up chat logs from people and like yelling at like Apex Crypto
but with a doc. But that's now two pieces of person identifying
information. Yeah. It's not a principal position against doxing
at all. That's not That's Dan loves doxing. Dan there's literally
nothing Dan enjoys more than somebody talking about him that
he can go and look up like their private information then menace
them with it. He just randomly insulted me on multiple occasions
and then was a little baby when I actually confronted. Uh, and
so I will continue to call him fat at every
All right. So, if you guys don't remember or if you weren't here
last night, you would have missed Dan and Nicholas Yorio having
like a a pretty pretty substantial argument on Nick's stream.
Okay, we'll rewatch this Shamu tweet. All right, we'll re we
rewatch this guy cuz I don't think Kelly caught it. All right,
and this will be important context for Kelly going into this.
So Dan went on Nicholas Dearu's stream last night to argue that
Hassan
did dox this guy or Hassan was doxing this person. Right now,
I'm not sure because I I haven't looked into the particulars
of that. That might be something we do today. Look more into
like what Hassan did exactly. I only got a summary from Queenman,
so I can't speak to it explicitly. Uh semantics, thank you for
the gifted sub.
So
I believe what happened was Hassan was getting like a comment
about how he should be hung or something from somebody in his
chat, right? Like basically like you deserve to die. And what
he did was somebody went and looked up the YouTube. It was like
something cryptoyt,
right? So somebody hanged. You deserve to be hanged. Sure. So
somebody said that and and somebody googled that name and went
to the YouTube channel or went to the YouTube channel or whatever,
right? because it's clearly like a YouTube channel name and they
were like, "Oh, you should look at this guy." But they gave him
the wrong YouTube, okay? Because the YT was actually in the YouTube
handle. Usually when somebody adds YT to the end of a handle
on Twitch, you would go to that handle without the YT in it,
right? So somebody So he did that. He looked at that guy, called
that guy ugly or something. And then he moved on and he like
actually looked at the real channel and continue to brag on the
real channel. Okay. But he didn't like dox. He didn't actually
like dox somebody. He was just looking at like he literally was
looking at the name of this person that they were advertising
with online, right? It the same thing would happen if if somebody
like
googled Nicholas Dioro or something, right? Like the name like
obviously you shouldn't use the name Nicholas Dioro if you don't
want people googling the words Nicholas Dioro, right? The proper
nouns Nicholas Dioro.
Yeah. is uh
someone is not looking after their identity very well if they're
like not taking at least one step to like hide anything.
Yeah. Like I assume that person is fine with being public. Now
should you go to like their to their like private their like
Facebook or something and like start showing pictures of their
family? No, you shouldn't do that. That would be kind of silly.
Yeah, that happened. Pensive goat. That did happen. Um,
yeah. I think I think if you're going to use like slurs in somebody's
chat and they like look you up, they like Google your name, they're
like, "What the who is this person?" and it goes to like something
that ties to your I just think you're probably not operating
in a way that anyone else would expect on the internet. Okay.
Yeah. You're going to get accidentally doxed at the very least
by people that aren't even meaning to do anything like that.
It's just like Yeah. And this YouTube channel, like it was a
YouTube channel and it was uh what else could you say? It was
a YouTube channel and it was like for a business. It wasn't like
the guy's personal thing or it shouldn't have been his personal
thing, right?
So anyway, it's unlikely that anybody would really seriously
say Hassan was being doxed. But Dan went on, I believe, to argue
with Nicholas that no, this was doxing. No, this does violate
the Twitch to right. And Nicholas was pushing back. And I think
uh it eventually got into
it eventually got into like a real argument and then it got into
a real real argument today. Okay. So, we'll watch this clip and
then we can go through the tweets today cuz I'm sure Kelly will
find it very funny. That's the game. You I'm not playing the
game. I'm trying to get the truth.
I think so. I think you'll find it very
I'm sorry
over here. So,
I have to agree with him. What did you say, Kelly? Not a big
fan of fats. So over here, so I feel like I have to agree with
him though if he's the one saying didn't really dox anyone. Yeah,
I just want to make it clear for everybody in that instance.
She means Nick and not me. Okay, just to make I know that could
have been confusing for some people. She does mean that it's
not my game. That is the game. Like if you're out here like I
can't believe you're pulling up tweets from 10 years
Listen, bro. I don't know what to tell you. That that the world
that is never changing ever, no matter what. That is what everyone
does all the time. Stop. It will never end. He just randomly
insulted me on multiple occasions and then was a little baby
[__] when I actually confronted.
Uh, and so I will continue to call him fat at every opportunity.
I don't really remember what it was
Why is she obsessed with pointing out fat people? Isn't Jay-to
pretty chubby himself? Yeah, she calls me fat all the time. Yeah,
exactly. I do.
Like my last messages were literally calling both Justical and
Dioro fat before my last account got equal equal
I saw I saw that post on Twitter from people. It was like it's
so gross that Kelly Jean calls Destiny fat when she hangs out
with Jtock. It's like she calls me fat and Nick fat and Destiny
fat. I I don't know what to tell you, bro. Like it's not like
she leaves me out. It's not like she just ignores it. It's not
like she just leaves me out. Okay. She does it all the time.
By the way, she also doesn't even know what I look like. That's
also true. She just calls me it anyway.
I honestly I started doing it ages ago because I just started
calling anyone when I don't know what they look like fat because
I assume if they're being hostile online and I don't know what
they look like, they're probably fat. And usually I'm right.
Fat, ugly, bold, or short. There's like one of these.
Uh J, I thought you claim to be skinny now. Uh I don't know if
I'd say I'm skinny. I can run. I've got like uh some cardio going,
but I wouldn't say I'm like skinny. I think when Kelly called
Destiny fat the first time, I was like, I'm probably fatter than
that guy. Not by a lot, but like probably by a little I mean,
if I had to be funny, like specific overall, not so much fat,
but he has a big fat gut that kind of hangs out over his trousers.
So, he's just very unfortunate build. He needs to get some lipo
on his abdomen or something. Maybe he could talk to uh Oh, who
is the guy who got that? Who is the dude? Oh, it's the Endure
guy. Uh oh, I can't I I can't get it. No, no, no. The Endure
guy. Yeah. Is it MFD? We MDA. Why can I not think of his name?
No, no, no. Somebody give me the name.
Do the whole thing. MLDD. MLDD. Yes. I still can't think of what
MLDD means.
Modern life dating. Or you could just like How is that so tough?
work out. That would also help cuz then everything else would
be like bulked out properly in an aesthetic way and his stomach
would be less of an issue.
That's also an option. That'll never Be an option. You could
pay for lipo, though. Oh, what's up, Dan? We're covering all
your stuff.
Yeah, we're going to cover this whole thing. Um, I was of the
opinion I didn't see how many times you guys tweeted each other.
I was of the opinion that this was just like totally made up
when I saw you like talking about it in Spicy.
Yeah, I got I got all your stuff. Yeah. Um, Dan, I'm going to
give you some free advice while you're here, okay? Stop referencing
uh stop referencing Lady Boy Mindset, okay? You do not want to
use this guy as your legal counsel. I realize a bunch of us kind
of want you to. And
I do not do it. Okay? Do not do it. Do not do it. All right.
That guy is I'm scared to I'm scared to ask who that is with
a name like that. It sounds like
Oh, I thought you said lady boy said. What the [__]
um
but he actually he actually might be he actually might be Wes's
council because in fact one of the services he sells under his
consultations is explaining to people how you yes you Kelly or
anybody fleeing the west because women the west not the west
people fleeing the west because women in the west are who are
doing like uh sugar daddy sugar daddy websites and like only
fans okay if you're fleeing the west to go east to go to Asia
Okay. Because these women are, you know, they're they're real
women. They they want a family. They are traditional. Okay. If
you're doing that, he's got a service for you where you can Oh,
whoops. I don't want to do that. Wait, no. I just want the I
just want the explanation. Relocation consult Thailand only.
So, Wes could have talked to this guy about moving to uh
people flee the west because he has a lady boy mindset. True.
Yes. But he uh he basically consults with people on how to move
to the east. And he's one of the red pill guys who is like, "Yeah,
the west has fallen." This is Dan's This is Dan's favorite lawyer
on the internet, by the This guy.
Dan. This is your boy. This is your favorite lawyer on the entire
internet. Ladies and gentlemen, it's time to go east. Let's let's
hope he doesn't know about this so much cuz uh he looks like
a guy that would do this to the uh what is what does it say on
his YouTube des Oh, is my Oh no, my my Oh no, Kelly, my thing
died. Wait,
I don't know what that means. I need my
uh my trackpad died. Give me two seconds. So, I'm going to read
this real quick though for Dan just in case he's still here.
Helping the everyday person escape the collapsing west for the
east. We'll have information on visas, relocation, housing, business,
and more with unfiltered no BS explanations offering practical
advice for those looking to make a permanent change.
The collapsing west.
The collapsing west. Dan, you're trying to say you're trying
to say somebody else is your favorite lawyer because you've been
you've been touting this guy all over Twitter. Okay, this is
your guy. I'm not asking you if it's your guy. I'm saying he
is your guy. This is your guy. You can't reference this guy all
the time and then not have him be your guy.
He's your guy.
That's how it is. Just like when Willie Mack references Destiny
all the time with no critical thought. All right. That's his
guy. Even if he wants to say he doesn't like him, that's his
guy. Okay. Sorry. I need to be right back, Give me a second.
I see.
I was in the middle of reading something
and then I got cut off. Never mind. Oh, I see.
No, he's not forbidden from calling in. I don't Does he have
the thing? I think anyone with Notable can call in. He could
totally call in. I I do not know
enough about the
He could totally call in.
He could totally call in. He's the only one who's discussed the
issue. Okay.
I'm saying he weighs in on a lot of issues like uh the collapsing
west. These white women are complete. They're all over Only Fans.
They're all over sugar daddy websites. Okay.
Is it really that wrong for a guy to want to go east?
Is it really that wrong? Oh boy. A strange
strange thing.
There goes Jay- Sock always running to the Destiny defense when
talking about Willie. I am Willie for having no conscious thought
process of his own.
I'm sorry that that's confusing to you, King of Sorrow.
Just go over my Twitch uh Twitter post with the most disingenuous
take possible, please. I know that will be difficult for you.
Do you mean like do you mean that won't be difficult for me?
Oh, you're joking. Listen, King of Sorro, I'm sorry you're not
here all the time. You understand why I wouldn't think you're
joking? A lot of people actually reacted that way to my tweet.
They're like, "Wait, why didn't you address the argument?" There
is no argument. He just says, "Destiny is right about everything
he just said, which is only one statement.
Dan unfollowed me on Twitter." Rude.
Oh, he wouldn't have unfollowed me. We're good friends. He did
unfollow. You
soft block me, you [__]
You soft blocked me, you.
I'm following you back. Oh, wait. No, I am following you. No,
you you actually just unfollowed me. You actually just unfollow.
Get the out of here, Dan. Get the out of here. Hold on. Chloic
was right about you. You know what? I wasn't I wasn't sure I
was going to pull this clip, but Chud Logic was right. Let me
find it. Let me find the clip. Where's the clip? It's funny because
he must have done it in the last few days, too. So, I guess Destiny
crying about being wrong at chemistry must have been the final
nail in the coffin. He's like, "Dan, you must unfollow now."
Dude, imager with its proxy is so annoying. Child Logic was right
about you, Dan.
Oh, look at that. Is that actually Dan? Dan, you're such a little
wretch, dude. Honestly, I think your campaign is absolutely pathetic
and uh you're a sick sick individual, to be honest.
Hope you're well though. Other than that, hope you're well.
Dan said you can't give the no names Personal issue with you,
but I think you're I have more followers than he does. By quite
a lot if no names,
but I think you're an absolutely disgusting lying freak, to be
honest. That's very uh to keep it real, okay? Nothing personal,
okay? Nothing I just got perpetually trapped in an attic, by
the way. What is happening with this guy?
This guy's like a hostage release video from Afghanistan as we
speak. Wait, Dan went on Chud's stream today. No way. There's
no way Dan went on Chud's stream today. Get out of here. He's
just typing in chat. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Chud's a wild one. Don't worry, Dan. Chud says mean things about
me, too. Okay, but we have to we have to take, you know, the
medicine hurts going down. It doesn't taste good. Okay, it's
bitter going down, but sometimes he has valid things he says.
Okay.
So, some of that will be performative and some of that will be
valid and it's up to you to stomach it and and and
then figure out which is which. Okay.
Yes. Exactly. Snake called me a no name today. I mean Dory, Dan,
we are going to get to your tweet. I promise. All right. I'm
going to restart this for Kelly cuz we need this context for
Kelly. What the I'm very sure that Dan and everyone else follows
a lot more people that a lot less followers than me.
So, I don't think that has anything to do with it. Anyway, sorry.
We need to go back to this. Let's check it out. So, this was
uh Dan and Dan and Nicholas having a little argument there. Kelly,
that's the game. You I'm not playing the game. I'm trying to
get the truth. I'm sorry. Like, I'm not going to play your game.
It's not my game. That is the game. Like, if you're out here
like I can't believe you're pulling up tweets from 10 years ago.
Listen, bro. I don't know what to tell you. That That's the world.
That is never changing ever. No matter what. That is what everyone
does all the time. Non-stop. It will never end. Ever. And your
side. It's not a good argument. It doesn't m It doesn't It doesn't
need to be a good argument. That's what everyone does. You're
just throwing at the wall. What makes you better than him? What
makes you better than Hassan P? I'm glad you asked because my
side is honorable and it was obviously taken out of context.
Their side meant it and they still haven't changed.
So, it's just sides. That's I mean, yeah, this is like this is
completely That's that's the big issue though. That's why that's
like unironically that's why we can't do a show.
Well, it's not me saying that. No, it was you. You just said
that. No, I'm saying that's how the game is. That is the game
100%.
All right. Well, do you do not do you not think that that's what
people do on Twitter all day, every day? So, this is good. This
is uh Nicholas. He's broken the chains today. Okay. He's unshackled.
He's broken the chains.
He's being honest about stuff. You love to see it. Okay. Nicholas
is reborn. Nicholas is back. Yeah, but you're the guy on Twitter's
ban. There's plenty of examples, as it is, that are stronger.
But all you do is put fodder in there for him to respond and
get an easier uh clap back with. I don't know. I I kind of disagree
with you. I mean, especially looking at how many people thought
that this was egregious. I think that you might be having a very
commentary brain to take here versus what the commentary take
is is to not lie.
This isn't this isn't the lie, though. I think you're looking
where you circled half a sentence. Wait, what did you think that
was? Okay. Also, Twitchers,
I'm so sorry, Twitchers, okay? But it's uh it's not going to
be a Twitch stream day today, okay? We're not gonna we're not
going to go very long, guys. If you are on the Twitch stream,
you're going to have to head over to the kickstream. We are live
on kick and
and Twitter, okay? Or watch the Twitter stream. Either one, but
watch the ones that don't take away from my lovely, lovely kick
income, okay? So, I'm going to I'm going to send you guys over
there. And yeah, we'll see you in a little bit. Bye. Sorry, Kelly.
I need to set up my
my kick income thing. No worries.
There we go. All right. Showing there I'll back it up. A screenshot
where you circled half a So Nicholas is saying that when Dan
when you like uh when you do these um we do these attacks that
are like super disingenuous and leaving out context. You basically
give people like a good way to clap back against you. You give
people a good way to clap back against like your movement. It
actually hinders the movement in the long term. It can be effective
very very short term. Okay. But it long term it will always come
back to bite you in the ass. Always. Always. Always.
And that's why the side of the truth always wins in the end.
In the end, the side of the truth always wins. Okay. It might
it might take a long time, but it will win in the end. It's how
you should live your life. Jordan Peterson said that or something
like that. I forget. Wait, what did you think that was supposed
to be showing there? The publish confidential information part
was pretty important in that sentence. That's a pretty That's
a pretty important factor when determining doxing is the is the
confidential information part. We've kind of exhausted this.
I'm going to get back to my segment now, but that's really I
I I'm not really super happy with that
Did you see the um Don't forget you go the mic one. That's a
much more mic is here. It's on the list.
Oh, you don't like the cut, Dad? What was cut out? Do you think
maybe Listen, we'll go to your tweet. Okay. We're just watching
We're just watching this. Dan, I also think you should look away
right now. Okay. This is brutal. This is going to be a brutal
one.
And I have to point it out. I have to call out what happens here.
And I don't want to do that with you in the chat. It's up. Okay.
Because Kelly, you're going to need this. You're going to need
to watch this and we're going to have to talk about it. And it
is uh it is rough. I'm going to talk about it cuz Mike retweeted
something about me. So, I'll let you go.
Dude, holy
important factor when determining doxing is the is the confidential
information part. We've kind of exhausted this. I'm gonna get
back to my segment now. That's really I I I'm not really super
happy with that combo.
Did you see the um
Dude, he doesn't even wait until Dan leaves to go. I was not
super happy with that combo. I think I'm going to get back to
my segment. You should go. Oh man, I was not super happy with
that combo. Dan like responds. Don't forget you go to the mic
one. That's a much more The mic stuff is here. It's on the list.
I'm going to talk about it cuz Mike retweeted something about
me. So, I'll let you go. He has to do it a second time, dude.
Holy [__] I just fed just you don't have to be upset
about it then. I'm just He's literally like kicking. He's literally
like, "Yeah, that sucked. That guy sucks." And you're like, "Hey,
just you should try this out." And he's like, "Yeah, you should
go."
It's just brutal. It's brutal. That's all. The small commentary
channels for a month. What the bro? Holy [__] dude.
All right. So, we're going to we're going to run this segment
as quickly as possible, I guess. I don't know cuz this is going
to get reposted everywhere. Okay. Okay.
Okay,
go look at any OP post about this. Oh, should I go look at the
the tweets from the guy who hates Hassan and has built his thing
around hating Hassan, right?
Should I look But hold on. That's actually not fair to O. O has
like he does a lot of other good stuff, too. Okay. He has a lot
of other good stuff, but a very core base there is people who
hate Hassan. I don't want to I don't want to totally on that
guy. All right.
Um, but yeah, it's like just a lot of Hassan hate. Of course,
the responders to a are going to hate Hassan and just do anything
they can to support Hassan or support hating Hassan. Of
I'm standing.
Do you think that I would want to agree with the Oreo?
So, this has nothing to do with being brain broken. I dislike
him more than mostly everyone else here. I don't
It's I'm not totally brain. And then I will give you the opportunity.
I will read through your post. I'll read through the whole thing.
But I had to set this up because this was last night and we were
laughing about it last night. That's all. Kelly's peeking hard.
Wait, Kelly, can you speak again?
Am I? I don't know. Hello. No, you're fine. Maybe you might have
just leaned in and yelled a little bit. That's all. Oh, okay.
Okay. Hold on. Wait. I just got like something. What is this?
Is Dan talking about legal mindset? careful because the attorney
that did this is brilliant is what I would say. First of all,
that's absolutely not It absolutely
know for effect it is
Destiny was so nice to you here, Dan, too. Destiny could have
I know. I know cuz Destiny and I both don't like this guy's legal
opinions for the same reason. Oh, wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
No, Dan, you are you are actually true. No, no, no. You are you
are right. Sorry. That clip got linked to me with Dan on legal
mindset. I watched this video. I reacted to it on stream. This
is you talking about the lawyer who wrote Ethan's thing, right?
Yeah, you This is you talking about the lawyer who wrote Ethan's
thing. Sorry, I got linked a clip and I got excited. That's too
That's too bad. But
I think you'd say that about Legal Mindset, too.
Hi. I I recognize it. I recognize it. But
Destiny doesn't respect legal mindset either. Okay. Because if
you remember when Legal Mindset did his video on Destiny, he
said the Florida revenge, the harassment statute, uh, that audio
recordings could be a visual depiction. That was his analysis.
What? What? How is that not Hold on. How is that not good faith?
Okay. Well, we'll go. I just If he thinks that we are
why is he asking us for coverage? I'm so
I don't know.
Uh, but it doesn't we don't trust me, we don't need Dan's opinion
to give him fair and balanced coverage, okay? We'll make fun
of him. We'll we'll do everything here, but
we uh we will be totally fair when we get to his uh his tweets,
okay? We'll be totally fair.
I promise. I promise, Dan.
All right. What do I have here? Oh, I've got like the Shimu thing.
This is Nicholas Dioro. The Shimu thing is
after.
So Nick Nick tweets this earlier on today. I believe this is
where the responses start, right? This is Dan and Nick going
back and forth. I didn't have a time to get all of the stuff,
thank you. Thank you for that. Uh thank you for that tweet.
Who just sent that? The kino real McGavin, thank you very much.
Dan's extensive chat GPT lawyer research actually exonerates
son. Hate to see it. Uhoh.
Well, we'll have to check it out. Oh,
okay. Hassan didn't dox anyone in this clip. He pulled up the
public YouTube channel of Apex CryptoYTYT. YT means YouTube.
This clip has been shared thousands of times across Reddit and
Twitter. But not once have I seen a single person think to blur
the docks because it doesn't exist.
Just going to point out that Hassan the Hun still has not been
the recipient of a ban for displaying a weapon regardless of
if it was later revealed to be an airsoft in a threatening manner
and doxing two people, one of whom was a completely innocent
victim of Hassan's stupidity. That per I don't think that person
got doxed on stream after almost 5 days, while the person in
his chat who made a threatening remark was justifiably banned
instantly. Hassan violated multiple parts of the toos, some of
which have resulted in other streamers being permanently banned
from Twitch in the past for the exact same thing or lesser the
exact same or lesser versions of the offense. And yet nothing
happens. I will say
Turkey Tom pulled out an airsoft rifle on my stream. I got perma
banned for that. I got permabanned when Turkey Tom did a funny
bit with his airsoft rifle on my stream. Okay,
but listen,
that's to be expected. Okay,
I'm sorry. You don't ban your one of your highest like earning.
They don't even pay Hassan for ads anymore. He's like one of
their highest earning streamers for them. Of course, they're
not going to ban. Oh, of course they're not going to ban him.
No, Stephen Jelly on Twitch. I got banned because Turkey Tom
had his gun out. I But he asked me. He literally said, "Is it
okay?" I'm not blaming him for that. He literally said, "Is it
okay?" And I was like, "Yeah, it's a funny bit. Go for it." Yeah.
Turkey Tom's a funny guy.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. It was the Zen shortage.
So Nicholas
is responding to this tweet saying like, "Oh, obviously it's
not a dox." Like literally, you're showing the picture of the
guy, right? You're showing this guy's face.
Why Why wouldn't you blur it if this is a dox? Okay. Anyway,
Nicholas continues, "A commenter told Hassan he was being treasonous.
So, what does he do? He was calling for Hassan to be hung. He's
saying he's saying Hassan should have been should be beaten.
In response, Hassan pulled up two YouTube channels and showed
their public profiles. This does not constitute doxing by anyone's
definition." True.
Yeah, we don't think that's doxing. So, it's time to crusade
Iran in Gaza. Badani communist. Let's go to war against the left.
To some getting beat up soon. Mdani is such an idiot. We will
fight the left before they elect a communist. Every infidel shall
be hung for treason.
H.
I don't know what that was. Hang Manni for treason. Hang Hassan
for treason. YouTube. Stephen Jellian. YouTube.
If your response to any of the above blatant lies is butddy he
brandished a fake gun. First of all, I agree and I think that
should be it should be a 24-hour ban at a minimum. But all this
tells me is that you're completely morally bankrupt and unable
to acknowledge when people are straight up lying. There are a
lot of examples of Assan getting special treatment over on Twitch.
We don't need to make up fake doxing claims to enhance our pathetic
fake brandishing fake gun brandishing claim. Also, if your response
to this thread/evidence is he took off the orange tip and that's
illegal in the state of California, I just want you to know I
loathe you.
The funniest implication is pushing that uh in pushing this is
they've retroactively made Lance the Surfs win his debate with
Destiny. He argued that referencing the failed public office
run of Mike from PA would be doxing despite his name literally
being first name from location he lives in. If pulling up the
public YouTube channel of Apex CryptoYT, a Twitch chatter whose
name is a reference to the YouTube is considered doxing, then
Mike from PA was actually doxed. True. Yes. True. Wait, this
guy's face is his PFP on Twitch. Oh, yeah. Okay. Like, who cares?
Who cares? Who cares? Who cares?
Yeah, it's not a big deal. did like the worst maybe not the worst
this would classify as if he kept going on it I guess as someone
that hadn't protected themselves maybe you could argue for harassment
at a certain point but I can't see in any capacity how this could
be doxing and considering the guy first said multiple times that
he wants him to be hanged
I don't even know I don't even know at that point
yeah it's more like uh this guide, right? The me Oh, no.
Kelly's mic is insane right now. Really?
Let me listen. Hang on. One, two, three. One, two, Oh, hold on.
I Yeah, I turned you up a Now that I think about Whoops. I turned
you up a bunch so I could hear you over the music at the start
of the stream. This is better. This will be way better. Sorry,
guys. Oops. Whoopsie. Okay. All right.
Kelly should be way better now. Um, okay. from here.
Now, there's a there's a Dan response to this. I don't know if
he quote tweets it. Does he quote tweet it? I can't check the
quote tweets, Nicholas. Just unblock me. I'm not even I don't
even talk to you on Twitter. Just unblock me so I can view quote
tweets. What the Yeah, I know. Neo, don't worry. We're going
to get to it. We're going to get to all of it. All right.
where's the uh where's the Dan response here? Dan did this first,
which is pretty funny. Oh, wait. Is this one first or I have
to go to the do I have to go to the pictures? I might have to
go to my imager album. Hold on. Okay. What time is this at? 8:55.
Oh god, these screenshots are from somebody else. Oh, I'm kind
of I'm kind of losing it on my timeline here. Dan, did you Oh,
is Dan not here? I can't tell if Dan quote tweeted this or if
he just made his own tweet cuz there's this guy right here, right?
There's this one where Dan
Nicholas response. Oh, here we go. This is it. I get the impression
we're like a last
Everyone else has said to Dan, "Dan, this is kind of dumb." So,
he came here as a last resort. And still, we're saying, Dan,
this is giving up.
Dan loves massaging narratives. He goes he goes around everywhere
and he will massage the narrative anywhere. The funny thing is
is when I do read this, which I will shortly, okay, I'm going
to be totally fair. I'm going to be fair in every way, but this
is not going to be fair. I'm gonna say these two to these two
tweets were made what within an hour two hours of each other,
right? Willie Mack had a choice. Willie Mack had a choice between
the guy he's doing a podcast with and his friend who basically,
you know, if it's not Destiny telling Willie Mack what to think,
it's Nicholas, right? Like we've established that, you know,
Nicholas himself has said Willie Mack just can't really evaluate
information on his own. I kind of have to always point him back
in the right direction, tell him how to actually do his job.
So William Mac, you know, he went with the old faithful.
Uh, he said something akin to that. Yeah, he said I'm not I'm
not I'm not saying something that's like totally false. I believe
he said something like, you know, Willie some Willie gets it
wrong a lot of the time. I have to point him back in the right
direction. I have to like get him back on track, right? Did he
call him like a total? No, but he he said something like that.
Am I embellishing it slightly for stream? Yeah, a little bit,
but not a lot. Not in essence at all. In essence, that is 100%
true. Okay. Anyway, but Willie Mack, you know, he he could he
could retweet his uh his new podcast co-host or he could retweet
Nicholas. And he chose Nicholas. Okay, he went with Nicholas
here. Oh boy.
Oh boy. Oh boy. I I hope that gives Dan some pause, but who knows?
Probably not. Probably not. Okay, now we got Now it's time, Kelly.
We got to read. We got to read this legal definition his post
here. Okay. Over under on the podcast not making it till episode
15. If Willie Mack has any sense at all that podcast will not
happen. They will not hit episode one. Okay. There's one thing
that I don't I don't get here. Like is Dan trying to imply that
he's really against doxing but he's best friends with Destiny.
Well, and he literally has talked about how awesome doxing is
and how he likes to dox people like multiple times.
and people confused
just very confused.
Yeah, it's not a principal position against doxing at all. That's
not that's Dan loves doxing. Dan There's literally nothing Dan
enjoys more than somebody talking about him that he can go and
look up like their private information and then menace them with
it. Like it's
Dan loves stop anti-semitism, a prolific docer. I He does. Yes,
he does. True.
Dan literally brags. Do I still have that imager album laying
around somewhere? I had an imager album of Dan telling that story
and I was just like, "Dude, there's no way he just told the story
about it was some guy who like was re-uploading." Oh Jesus, is
my mic still working? I just hit my microphone. Oh, it's working.
He was re-uploading. This guy was re-uploading anything else
to Spotify. A really thing to do. And Dan like emailed this guy
and was like, "Hey, stop doing this." And this guy was like,
"You Dan." And so Dan found his information, called him at work,
uh, called the guy's like boss and said, "Hey, your employees
like your employees like doing this shit." They got the guy,
the guy was like, "What the are you what? What?" It's I can't
remember if he called the guy first and the guy had his boss
pick up or if the guy's bot picked up first and he asked for
the guy. I can't remember which way that went, but it was like
uh Yeah, it was it was crazy. He did that to someone's wife.
No, that was last year. That was where he uh came back was because
that Glenn the Golden guy was um or Greg the Golden, whatever
that guy's name was. That guy was like saying something anti-
saying Dan was like Desi's massage handler or something. And
Dan was like, "Oh yeah, well
you're I'm going to let your wife know that you're talking about
me." He like messaged his
which listen, sometimes that could be some of those things could
possibly be like funny in a vacuum depending on how insane those
guys are going. Like with the Glenn the Golden guy, there's some
argument that he's doing anti-Semitic like conspiracies against
Dan. There's like maybe some argument there that you could do
it, but just like reveling in it and posting about it seems a
little
Seems a little much. Anyway, so no, not a principled stance against
doxing by any means. But it's okay cuz
listen, if he has an argument legally, then he can just make
the legal argument. He doesn't have to make the moral argument.
He just make the legal When did get here? I just joined. What?
Just join. I didn't even hear the noise. Like literally in response
to his joint Holy. I didn't hear the join sound. That was why
I was confused. Yeah. You look Dan stuff. Did you see him in
spicy chat earlier? He was just in my chat earlier. Just here.
Yeah. And I do have some some posts from him in spicy chat that
he didn't redact fast enough. Funny guy. Funny guy. Funny guy.
That Wait, hold on. Was he saying something new in spicy chat
now? No, I just say I know. I just think Kevin is just a funny
guy. How'd you like him?
He is kind of a funny guy. Yeah, I think he's a fun guy. Funny
guy.
Well, we're no name now, so uh don't know how I feel about that
anymore. Oh, yeah. Dan unfollowed me on Twitter and I uh called
him out. What a move.
It's like, dude, it's just so funny. He was like posting the
screenshot of Nick Dior retweeting my tweet and then he's like,
"Wow, you know you're down bad when this is happening." And I
was like, "Dude, I don't think you know what's going on here.
I don't think I think you're reading this correctly at all."
He uh he missed the stream last night. Oh, did you see this one,
though? Did you see um Okay, Willie had one of two choices. Okay,
one of two choices. Nicholas made his post. Dan made his post
and Willie made his decision. Okay, he's he's riding with the
guy who always tells him how to not look. Okay, not just not
the guy who feeds him information, but the guy who like
Right. Willie Max repost Nick. Try tried and tested strategy.
Okay. Just just follow Nick. Okay. Willie has gotten by on this
for years.
It's not going to fail him now. Well, he's easy to follow. Can't
miss him, can you? Oh, man. I hate to I will say the one nice
thing that I feel like I would reciprocate, okay, is
I noticed Willie in the Daliban community, okay, where they consistently
try to post the fail docs of me and like I guess tag me with
it and try to spread it as much as possible and Destiny retweets
these these tweets all the time. Willie did go to one of them
and go, "Hey, this seems like bad. Maybe we shouldn't be doing
this guys."
It's like, hey,
uh, and then there's a whole bunch of people who are like, wait,
Destiny didn't dox this guy. It's like, yeah, he did. Wait, show
me proof. It's like, uh, well, here's the proof. And then they
just disappear.
Like, okay. So, when Yeah, people just be doing it all the time.
It's very funny. King of Soro.
It's It's like funny how they think it's menacing
when they're like the least. They like can't they couldn't set
off a spark if they rubbed their brain cells together. Okay,
it's like there's nothing going on there. There's no light in
their eyes. There's no light in their life. These people are
just complete losers. God. Anyway, uh well, OMFG is pro. The
issue is it's not the community so much as Destiny retweeting
all of those, right? Himself personally and him publishing what
he says is the docs in the first place and him going around and
saying, "No, no, no. This is really him. I promise." All over
the place. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm guessing Destiny isn't able
to support Dan at this trying time because he's too busy retweeting
what he thinks is your docs. So even Destiny's like, "You know
what? I can't really make this argument right now, Dan. I got
other things to do."
He's doing it. He's making it happen. We're about to read Dan's
tweet. I have not read Dan's tweet yet. Dan did not think I could
be good faith towards his tweet. So I'll read it and we'll we'll
do actual analysis here, okay? We'll see what gets said.
Many commentators seem hesitant to use the term doxing, perhaps
because it's often misapplied. Yet, both California's
and Twitch's terms of service to us clearly categorize Hassan's
conduct as doxing. In most situations, simply displaying a YouTube
profile is not doxing. It becomes so only when the disclosure
is intended to harass, intimidate, or embarrass the individual.
If the goal is, let's expose who this person is so others can
target them, the conduct likely meets the statutory and platform
definitions.
Okay. So, let's expose this person who this person is.
I don't think you can expose who this person. So, the issue is
is if somebody is if their name is literally I am trying to expose
who I am, then doing that probably can't be a form of harassment,
right? If they come to your community and go, "Hey, you should
be hung. You should be hanged. We want to hang this guy. Don't
we guys? Let's go. Let's this guy." Right? If somebody goes and
does that with a name that is saying, "Hey, I'm I'm exposed.
Look who I am." then they probably don't get that protection,
right? They just it's not even you don't even need to it doesn't
even matter about the like the hanging part isn't even relevant
to the doxing claim to me. It's like as simple as your name is
Apex CryptoYT.
The YT stands for YouTube. The point of your name is to direct
you to another account on another platform, which is the account
that Hassan goes and pulls up. There is clearly
I would almost go as far as to say it's like explicitly telegraphed
that you're allowed to look this guy up. You should look this
guy up. You should go look at this. That's what he wants you
to do. That's what his name is saying. So the idea is doxing.
No doxing. We would usually at least say the information has
to be like not intentionally linked to your current persona or
intentionally obscured. Usually that's why the confidential thing
is mentioned in the Twitch TOS. It's not because all doxing is
necessarily confidential information, but it's because that's
the sort of tone of the information that uh doxing usually applies
to. It's not just what your current username is.
Um yeah, obviously. Did you see what Dan's response to that was?
Um no, but I'm sure it's
it was Well, this time it was a YouTube account, but what if
it was a Facebook
Yeah, dude.
You love to see it. What if it was this entirely different thing?
Yeah. Yeah. What if it wasn't this situation? Well, then we handle
it. The thing he bakes in there, the thing he bakes in there
is that there's when the example he gives is someone comes into
your chat with with first name, last name FB like Apex Crypto,
but with the docs, but that's now two pieces of personal identifying
information. one of which uh you have reason to believe that
if that is the wrong person that is an incredibly sensitive piece
of information, right? You know, when you look at a legal name,
many people online do not want that name connected to their their
main persona and you know that there's not this, you know, it
would be bizarre to see, you know, like
John Smith FB in in a YouTube chat. you would immed that would
should immediately throw up warning signs to you. But there is
no reason there should be warning signs thrown up from an Apex
Crypto YT. It's a very common naming convention that uses a alias
username that you would have no reason to believe is obscured
or attempting to obscure any any PII.
Yeah, it's the opposite. It's communicating. Literally, it would
be their fault if they had PII on their YouTube that like was
there. They are attempting to expose it themselves. That's the
entire purpose.
Uh yeah, so the Twitch TOS, I do believe the Twitch TOS it's
likely not falling into at all. I don't know what the AB1979
if it's like, oh, you just can't as a streamer. Basically, what
the argument would have to be is that if you're a streamer and
you pull up somebody who's in your chat, any like anything to
do with them, including their profile, and single them out like
that's doxing now. Doxing. Yeah. And it's like that would be
an insane thing to do. And then the retired co, well, I don't
think it has stalking, but that's what the Twitch TOSS says.
And it's like, no, that's not what the Twitch TOSS says at all.
The Twitch TOS is very vague, and it it leaves room for lots
of different things because Twitch's to is not really expressed
in the letter of the toos. It's expressed in the enforcement.
Uh, and everyone knows this. Everyone knows this the case on
every social media site. No toos is followed exactly to the letter.
It's all expressed in the enforcement. And that's what you have
to look at. That's like probably people's number one complaint
about toss is like literally it's not clear. It's never clear.
I got
it's always open-ended enough to where basically anything can
be banned, right? It's like that's the point. That is the
Yeah. As many people are pointing out repeatedly over and over
again, this is just the Mike from PA debate where Lance from
the Surfs argued that it's doxing him to say he he lost a like
a what a Congress race or something congressional like primary
or something cuz that leads to him. His name's Mike from PA.
Yeah, you say that he lost
that happened when uh when Destiny was on Twitch, too. So, I'm
sure everyone's saying, "Well, thank god Twitch banned Destiny."
That darker. Sure everyone's saying that, right? Dan's Dan's
saying that. Wait, did they ban Destiny for that though? Well,
no. They didn't ban him for that. They don't know what they I
was like, "Holy shit." But they don't care what Hassan gets banned
for either. They just care that he gets banned. So, you know,
I I I don't see this any different. Oh, true. Actually, remember
when Dan went and found all of Dan Clansy's connected accounts
and came on my stream was like, "Let's look at his accounts."
Which was funny, by the way. And that I would say that's really
when you're Dan Kleiny 999 on that is pretty funny. It's probably
it's easily a little worse than this though, right? Like it's
easily um those are accounts that you have reason to believe
at Pornhub or whatever.
Yeah. You you have reason to believe those accounts are obscured
from public view or he wants them obscured from public view.
That's not someone's accounts is not something they generally
want pulled up and attached directly to their work. Uh now obviously
Dan K has kind of done that himself, but you you've got reason
to believe that. So I I'd say that meets a way higher standard
than someone.
Dan makes such bad arguments here. Oh no. He does he does the
Facebook argument in his post actually. I only saw it in the
video. Actually does it in this post. It's not good. Okay.
So in most situations, simply displaying a YouTube profile is
not doxing. Oh, we did this. If the goal is let's expose this
person, who this person is so others can target them. The conduct
likely meets the statuto and platform definitions. AB1979 and
Twitch TOS expressly lists public profiles, names, and photographs
as examples of information that constitutes doxing when revealed
with malicious intent. Conditions that appear to be satisfied
here at Nicholas Dioro view. Nicholas Yoryu's view that this
doesn't feel like doxing is understandable, but it overlooks
why the law and Twitch rule Twitch's rules exist. They're designed
to stop streamers from weaponizing off-platform information.
A Twitch account such as Jess Byron one on Facebook used to provoke
a streamer could belong to a vulnerable individual, for instance,
a survivor of domestic abuse. Twitch wants to prevent streamers
from directing harassment at such users. The emotional appeals
are very, very funny. It's like so transparent. It's just very
very shameless.
Um,
God, that would be like such a bad situation, but I would say
in that situation, it's like, yeah,
like it sucks for that person, right? If they're like a crazy
person, but I don't know, something else has failed there. Like,
somebody else has failed and this person making an account and
being there with that.
That's it's crazy. So, chatters can harass with no consequences.
Uh, I don't think so. But I also like I think if you went and
like googled um oh what would it be? If you like went and googled
and tried to like find their name and like uh then went and googled
and found like a Facebook profile that they really hadn't tried
to attach in 10 years. You have to follow like multiple links
that would probably definition simply pulling up a chatter's
Twitch profile with the intent to embarrass them would be doxing.
Yeah. And I was like that's Yeah. Exactly. That's like what 50%
of Hison's content is just getting one guide and pulling up chat
logs from people and like yelling at them. That's like 30 to
50% of his content in the first place. Like all of his content
is doxing apparently. This guy's picture by the way, which is
basically the only piece of doxed information from what I understand.
Maybe first name or something, but it's his picture is literally
his Twitch profile picture. Like his face is his Twitch profile
picture. Anyway,
uh the fact that a Facebook page or other profile is publicly
visible does not negate its identifying details. Accepting a
publicly available standard alone would render deed property
tax records and similar documents also containing names and addresses
fair game. Both the statute and toss instead focus on the actor's
intent. Accordingly, under California AB1979,
Hassan's disclosure was almost certainly unlawful. It plainly
violated Twitch's toss ban on doxing. Intent is central. Twitch's,
this is clearly chat GPT response. Uh, Intensive Central, Twitch
defines doxing as releasing someone's confidential information
to cause inconvenience, harm, embarrassment, or shame. So, what
is the confidential information that was released? Was it his
face? That wasn't confident. That wasn't confidential at all.
Right. That's that's not confidential. Was it the name of the
account? No, that's pointed to directly. That's not confidential.
Where's the confidential information that was released? Names,
photographs, and social media profiles. So, literally pointing
people at the YouTube, not the social media profile. photograph
was in the thing, not photographs name literally. I guess if
he said his first name, maybe that might not be in his Twitch
profile immediately.
An attorney has classifi has already classified Hassan's conduct
as doxing and other legal opinions would likely concur. In short,
regardless of personal impressions, Hassan's actions meet the
legal and platform definitions of doxing under both California
law and quick policy. Does not meet the legal definition of doxing.
It's like
we would have to look at the California law. What is it? He just
like sto
if you think what Hassan did there would would not be protected
under the first amendment like you would have to be so brain
dead to think that I truly so yeah I I posted the um
part of the doing law on Twitter but basically it's every person
who with intent to place another person in reasonable fear for
his or her safety or the safety of another person's uh immediate
family by means of electronic communication device and without
consent of the other person and for the purpose of imminently
causing that person unwanted physical contact, injury or harassment
by a third party. Electronically distributes, publishes emails,
blah blah blah blah. Makes way for downloading personifying information
including but not limited to digital image list PII
um which would be likely to incite or produce unlawful action
is guilty of a misdemeanor. And then it says, so it also defines
harassment as uh a knowing and willful course of conduct direct
at a specific person that a reasonable person would consider
as seriously alarming, seriously annoying, seriously tormenting
or seriously terrorizing the person and it serves no legitimate
purpose. Now obviously
if this even got
remotely charged or brought brought anywhere or even considered
a reasonable person would look at that and be like well this
isn't seriously tormenting or anything. The point here is this
person is saying they're trying to hang him and he's saying what
what are you going to do? What look at you what are you going
to do? He's not Hassan is not communicating he's got go do something
that he wants other people to go do something that this guy should
be in any fear simply that this guy should not attempt to hang
Hassan because he would fail and Hassan would shoot him that's
what he's saying so how could you be possibly tormented by the
idea that if you try to hang someone they're going to defend
themselves doesn't make any sense no uh it doesn't make sense
also can you link me are you looking at the same statute I am
cuz you went on a whole other thing here, but you might be looking
at some shortened version or
actually, one sec.
But, uh, so I would say probably you could argue how how would
you get this two doxing if somebody had like a Twick profile
and then Hassan got sent like a if Han threw it in Google and
like Googled the name and then like clicked on something and
pulled up like the guy's, you know, Instagram and showed pictures
of his family or something. If it was under the same name, if
it was under the same name, I still then you would probably get
there. I'd say like, you know, looking up uh like personal man,
I'm trying to think of how you would get this like two doxing
what it would have to be.
And it seems like you'd have to go a lot further than this. Oh,
like Ethan Klein did. I think you would argue that Ethan Klein's
conduct was significantly closer to doxing than what uh
than what Hassan has done here. Also, literally the Dan Clansancy
example is the ultimate shot of Dan's argument. What if Clancy
had a secret addiction and relapse sending him into a spiral?
Dan's argument wouldn't be justified here or wouldn't be justified
there. Wouldn't be Yes, it wouldn't be. Sure. Yeah. I'm like
I'm just trying to like connect it like how would you actually
make it make sense. So under the statute it's almost certainly
not there. I think just the the reasonability statute or the
reasonability standard rather is on its own enough. Uh let's
see here. That they would be likely that would be likely to incite
in incite or produce that unlawful action.
Hold on. What is the unlawful action? For the purpose of imminently
causing the other person unwanted contact, injury or harassment
by a third party, she was personally identifying information
that would be likely to incite or produce that unlawful action.
So, it's basically like does Assam want this guy like harmed?
Do you believe that? Do you Does H Assam want him harmed? And
is he saying something that will lead people to harm him? Oh,
is this uh the is this civil? No, this seems to be criminal,
right? Misdemeanor punishable by up to one year in a county jail.
No, no, that's that's for the that's that's that's separate.
So, what you're looking at the top there that describes the existing
No, no, no, no, no. Look, look.
Yeah, that's why I asked that's why I was like, dude, oh man,
I needed the uh Yeah. So, at the top there, it's describing the
cyber harassment law and then it goes on to explain the civil
course of action for doxing.
Oh, okay. Yeah. This is this is a civil course of action for
doxing. Civil course. Yeah, the civil Okay.
Yeah, the thing I've linked to is the is the actual cyber harassment
law, which I believe is is the criminal uh there's like a I think
they added like a new thing to it
section here is added to the civil code.
doces means an act. So, for the purpose of this section, the
following terms apply. I don't really need these terms right
now. Private cause of action lies against a person who docks
another person. Villaining plaintiff who suffers harm as a result
of being doxed in violation of subdivision B may recover the
following. Oh, it requires like actual harm from them being doxed
as
Emotional but I mean emotional distress is one of the harms.
So yeah. Yeah. Sadly I don't think um saying ugly skinny is quite
enough emotional harm. Well, and that wouldn't have been with
any intent either, right? Like he was he didn't intend to pull
up that guy's profile. It was like a unlucky happen stance. I
don't know.
Imagine the implications of either harassment or physical violence
with the implication of the gun being pulled out.
yeah, sure. Gather in chat saying it could potentially. This
guy chats in Pisco's chat. You should you should ask Pisco about
that because I I think you sounded really intelligent. We spoke
to him the other day.
Yeah. Uh, for anybody who can't tell, Queen is being very sarcastic.
He knows Hunter. He knows gatherer here. Hug
Just in case that just in case people
and he ran like a like six times and was like, I'm at work. I'm
at work. I can't call him right now.
I don't know what happened. Chill out. It's a It's a shame.
He turned into a guy that just like spam constantly was posting
in Desty's kick chat. It was just strange. No, that wasn't bad.
He was literally not engaging in any bad behavior there, Kelly.
It's fine.
He just likes incessantly arguing with people. That's That's
all it is. Arguing with him. Correcting making his point. I don't
know. It is what it is. Oh, none of those. Asana has gotten people
to the point where they're arguing it might be illegal to call
someone an ugly skinny looking at their YouTube channel. This
we we have truly
jumped the shark. Well, I think uh listen, at least
this allowed Nicholas Derio to break his chains, okay? He's no
longer shackled. He's no longer trapped in the basement of Dan
Saltman's mind. He can come out. He can give his opinions.
Tap just tap this guy over the back of the head and
he woke up. Okay, hold on. We didn't We didn't even finish reading
Dan's post. In short, regardless of personal impressions, Hassan's
actions Oh, sorry. Yeah. No, I read this. Hassan's actions meet
the legal and platform definitions of doxing under both California
law and Twitch policy. Unfortunately, Nicholas Dioro just got
owned by a 45-year-old man. Steve co.
Also, this is all chat GPD because until we get more attorneys
to comment on on both sides, sorry, on it. Both sides are dug
into the sand since legal mindset doesn't count. Lady boy Mindset
does not count. Correct. Lady Boy Mindset. Lady, the actual literal
lady boy Mindset tweet is crazy.
Okay. You saw the Ethan Ralph tweet, I'm assuming, right? I think
so. I think I scrolled past it,
No, it's not. I don't think it was recent unless it So, people
might be retweeting it recently. Okay. Legal mindset seems to
know a lot about Asian lady boys. I can understand having been
in the Philippines because I can say this and this is all due
respect. This is nothing about Lady Boy, not Lady Boy. It's just
the Philippines versus Thailand. Thailand has a more of a sub
cool attitude. You know, Philippines is way more aggressive.
Uh, I don't know, man. No. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The Filipino Lady Boys, I can tell this in Manila, right? now
I I just would never I've never thought of or conceived of somebody
being able to start a sentence with, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
The Filipino lady boys in Manila." Like, like, "No, no, no, no.
Shut the up. You have no idea what you're talking about." Like,
I remember that's like when I used to code, okay? You'd have
a bunch of autistic nerds sitting around in a circle who spend
all day every day coding. You get arguments like that. No, no,
no. shut the up with passion, right? I just feel like he knows
a lot about lady boys. You wouldn't expect that. You're an expert.
I can see how that was imported here are far more aggressive
than the Thai lady
until they're not until it changes until the ties snap and it's
like Yeah, but that's a different Yeah, true. You know, like
off rip. Off Well, because next thing you know, it's it's the
gangs in New York on Soy 11 between all the Lady Boys. Which
which was international news. everyone. Dude, I can't believe
I almost have more respect for this guy than I did before knowing
that he's just like
he just like lies. He's just like, "No, I didn't move here. I
didn't move here for any reason. I just love living here and
I don't I don't help people come here as passport bros and I'm
not a passport." He just lies. It's so It's so
H Okay, Dan posted his chat GPT research. Oh man, somebody said
the chat GPT research works against him. Hold on. Cuz the statute
explicitly trace public facing handles and URLs as personally
identifying information. It does not
Oh, what was that? That was a twisted rope. Thank you for the
four months. Let's go.
Viewer could sue the streamer for actual actual damages, statuto
damages of this much, punitive damages, blah blah blah. Defenses
are narrow. There's an exception for sharing info solely to report
a crime to law enforcement.
Case caveats. Case by case court would could still weigh intent
and whether a reasonable person would feel threatened. First
amendment public info arguments. The streamer could argue the
handle is already public and the stream was commentary. But AB1979's
drafters deliberately swept public opinion identifiers, public
online identifiers into the definition to blunt that
The viewers the viewers should consult a qualified California
attorney if they're considering action.
Interesting. I'm trying to see. Somebody told me that this was
uh not working, the whole chat GBT thing. But I'm probably not
going to read all of this.
Why would you? You want me to read the whole thing, Dan? You
want me to read the whole thing?
You want me to read all of it? You know what? I'll read all of
it. Okay, I'll read all of this and we'll we'll walk through
it. if California-based live streamer was if a California-based
live streamer was harassed by a live viewer with the name of
Joe Smith YT and the streamer then started waving a gun around
asking what are you going to do Joe Smith YT and then pulled
up the YouTube.com/josmith
yt to try to show the person's face would this be considered
a as doxing by
doesn't this imply that the face is obscured wouldn't this like
really fool chat GPT here Dan I feel like you need to include
that within the profile on that platform, the person uses their
face as a profile picture. Thereby, they are not obscuring the
profile picture at all. They're not obscuring that picture. You
wrote this prompt to get get the right answer here. How many
different attempts do you think it took?
Uh I'm not sure.
Hold on. Let me let me do a little test.
Let me do a little test here.
OCR some OCR really quick on this. I'm gonna I'm gonna run this
through chat GPT myself, guys, okay? And I'm going to modify
it slightly. Nothing wrong with chat GPT as long as you know.
I don't think there's anything wrong with saying it if you don't
know. I think there's something wrong with just pumping something
into chat GBT and regarding on Twitter as legal analysis. I think
Well, you should you should read it and see how it applies. Yeah,
I'm saying the tool itself isn't the problem. It's how it's used.
Yeah. The person's face is visible in the
uh harassed by a live viewer
on platform A with the username
of Joe Oh, I should pull this over. Hold on. With the username
of Joe Smith YT. And the streamer then started waving a gun around
a
an airsoft gun around asking what are you going to do Joe Smith
YT? and then pulled up youtube.com/jithyt
try to show the person's face which was already available
via their profile on the original platform
would this be considered doxing by AB1979
person's face is vis oh consider that Joseph YT is broadly understood
you should include uh I think you should include at the start
put in um that a chatter this chatter was requesting that Hassan
be hanged. I think you should make include that. Just see if
it factors out at all as well. Live viewer on a platform on platform
A by a live viewer on platform A. This live viewer is
calling for the death of the streamer
using Joe Smith YT. And the streamer then started waving an airsoft
gun around asking, "Okay, let's see what it says." I think based
on what I've seen, you're not adding that that the wrong person
was doxed.
Wait, were they doxed? No, he pulled up a YouTube channel. Yeah,
but hold on. Like, is that doxing? If if it's like literally
he's trying to Yeah, looking at someone's YouTube channel is
doxing. You don't understand. That's what the Twitch toos says
except totally ignore the part where it says often confidential
information. It's obviously vague and is only expressed through
the enforcement. It sounds like
it's like a argument.
I would expect this to still say that it would violate the law
because it ticks like the boxes superficially. I would expect
the reasonability arguments to be what strikes this down, right?
Like it would be about how reasonable it is. That is what I would
expect.
I was going to say it could fall under,
I'd imagine.
Okay. Did the streamer disclose personally identifying information
under AB? PII can include full legal names, home addresses, phone
numbers, email addresses, images of the person if not previously
public, other Oh. Uhoh.
Oh. A public YouTube channel URL by itself would not generally
qualify as PII under this law if the person has voluntarily made
it public. If the face or identity shown on that YouTube profile
was already publicly available and connected to that username,
it's less likely to be treated as sensitive private information.
Oh boy.
Oh boy. Was the intent malicious or to cause harm?
Uh, okay. Share the YouTube page to threaten intimidate. Oh,
this one's going to go in Dan's favor. Are you good? Are you
dying right now? Are you good right now? Chat, is that chattering
teeth? Is that
The streamer shared the YouTube page to threaten, intimidate,
or encourage harassment of the viewer, even in response to the
viewer's threats. This could arguably cons be construed as retaliatory
and harmful conduct. However, merely pulling up an already public
YouTube channel without sharing new private information is a
weaker case for a doxing claim. If the streamer intended to shame
or expose the viewer to harassment
uh by showing their face to their own audience, a court might
entertain a claim, but the strength of that claim would depend
on the circumstances. Was this information already publicly available?
California law and first amendment principles carve out exceptions
for information that the subject has made public that is part
of public records and that is part of legitimate a legitimate
public concern. If Joseph Smith YT had publicly linked their
face and identity that that username on their YouTube profile
then showing that YouTube profile likely would not constitute
doxing under the law even if the context was hostile. Bottom
line likely not doxing under AB1979 assuming the YouTube channel
and face were already publicly available. No additional private
information was revealed. The act was defensive, not a proactive
harassment campaign. But the aggressive tone waving an airsoft
gun and calling them out would it could expose the streamer to
other concerns such as threats or brandishing a replica firearm.
If the streamer encouraged their audience to harass Joe Smith
YT, that could potentially violate platform harassment policies
or in extreme cases still be cited under anti-ar statute. That's
what I said, but probably not AB1979 itself. Wow. It could be
harassment. Yeah. Wow. Wow. Crazy how when you actually describe
the situation in the chat GBT prompt, you get a completely different
answer. Wow. Hypothetically,
if a an un related third party
YouTube channel were pulled up in the same fashion due to mistyping
uh sorry, my typing mistyping the u the URL,
thereby
directing
people to uh sorry,
revealing the face of someone unrelated
on their public YouTube page. Could that be considered a violation
of AB1 1979?
This is a much more legally ambiguous situation. Here's precise
breakdown under this law. Does pulling up a public profile count
as a disclosure under AB1979? Yes, potentially if it meets other
the other elements. Defines disclosure as communicating or making
available personally identifying information of another person
to a third party. Showing an unrelated person's YouTube profile
and face live on stream could qualify as a disclosure even if
the information was already public because the act of pointing
out in a hostile context might change its legal character. Maybe
does it account as PII? Possibly images of the person, especially
if not connected to the public controversy. Online account users
names in combination with the identifying images information
that could reasonably allow others to locate or contact that
person offline. So in this case, if that guy had So that's difficult
for me because you're going to a public YouTube channel and there
is like a hostile context there. I think that would start to
come down to if something happened to that person. No, I would
imagine it reasonable to expect something would happen like it
I don't believe
that it's like it is sort of like the fire in a crowd building
type of standard to me. I thought that's generally if I thought
the first amendment is pretty strong in America. you have to
have like really good reason to think an actual like unlawful
action is going to occur as a result of what what you're doing.
Um, and there just isn't that with Hassan. They just is not a
reasonable person would not think, oh, someone says they want
to hang you and you accidentally go on the wrong YouTube channel
and then switch over to the next one. No one's going to be like,
oh yeah, that someone totally thought that someone was going
to go and this guy in real life. Someone has someone thought
someone was going to go and start dropping through this guy's
mailbox. like no, no one would think that was reasonable.
Okay, also just really quickly, um what about the intent requirement?
I believe the intent appears to go away if a song goes, "Oh,
we got the wrong channel before. Never mind, guys. Whoops."
Well, he didn't he didn't say, "Never mind. Whoops." Did he?
He didn't. He just sort of moved on. Well, I have to imagine
he went, "Oh, my bad." or something. All right. He didn't clarify
what what he did. He failed to clarify. He gets the new one.
He he says he says, "Oh, wrong guy." And then pulls up the new
one, then goes, "Oh, this is even worse." And then mocks this
guy for his
Sorry, but failed to clarify it was a mistake. So, it is clear
that it was a
It is clear. Yeah. Yeah. It's clear that it's not the right guy
immediately. Pretty immediately. He doesn't say sorry or apologize
or anything, but it is clear it's the wrong
Sure. So, what about intent? This is where things get complicated.
AB1979 requires the disclosure be made with the intent to cause
harm, harassment, or fear, or with reckless regard for whether
such harm might occur. If the streamer mistyped the URL, but
still mocked or ridiculed, they did wave the airsoft gun around
on while their face was on screen. Uh, failed to clarify quickly
that it was mistake. I think he did actually say, "Oh, wrong
guy. Move
He didn't say wrong guy. It was literally just wrong guy. I think
that's all he said. He said wrong guy. And then he said, he goes
like, "Oh, wrong guy." Reading a chatter. Um, and then he goes,
"This guy's, oh, this is even worse because he sees this guy
as an uglier, skinnier bitch." Um, so so he's mocking his appearance
instead.
Uh, I would say there is a chance that that guy, the third party
guy
might might have some case.
I don't think so. Given that Hassan said that it was wrong for
a second, I don't believe for a second guy would have a case.
That's I don't think I don't think a lawyer no lawyer would take
that on uh what is it where you take it with um you get a percentage
of winnings or whatever. What is the word for that? Um contingency
or contingency. Yeah, you take it on I think it's contingency.
Yeah. I don't think any lawyer would take this on contingency.
I don't think any lawyer on unless they just hated hated. No
win no fee, isn't it?
Yeah. No, literally it doesn't even matter. It's not even about
whether a lawyer would take it. I don't think they would win
a case like that. I literally I I don't believe for a second
that you could uh uh sue someone for that. I do not believe that.
And not have it like threat. Show me a single comparable case.
Show me like a single comparable successful
Sure. In any case, I do think the the like saying, "Oh, wrong
guy." And going to a different channel. And like I I think that
would be correcting the record. But
anyway, so we get we get to one of them possibly. Possibly. Wait,
wait, wait. If if you could if you could win a case like that,
Ethan Klein would have sued so many people so long ago. We would
not even be at this point. Ethan Klein would be sued himself,
right? As soon as you file that case and win it, Ethan Klein
would be getting sued like by a lot of people. So, you know what?
In light of that, I don't have principles. Yeah. Get this guy.
Go me this lawsuit. Let's go. Just total apocalypse. Let's everything.
Let's ruin everything. Burn all down. That's what people want,
right? That's what that's what we've decided we want now. It's
just awful legal precedent and just everything awful. One win
over Hassan so badly. I would literally blow the planet up. I
would literally nuke the world. At this point, I'm just going
to go like set myself on fire in the sun's. Okay.
And Saltman has tipped $3. Do you consider sharing nudes without
consent
Oh, somebody is asking Dan if he considers sharing nudes without
I think no because of the intent factor there, having to prove
the intent factor. But that is a funny question to
I'm sure Dan's going to go ask for a mod in the Daliban community
to remove potentially doxing information about uh people he's
friends with, right? I'm sure he's he's got a really principled
stance against doxing, right?
Well, no, they just fall back to Well, no, it's the Twitch to
I think that's stupid. I don't care about doxing. Well, that's
the Twitch to That's what he does every time.
It's not a Twitch TS. You know, it's just not a Twitch TOS.
Uh, okay. All right. So, hey, I think we just did a fairly good
faith questioning dance, right?
Oh, brandishing a gun while addressing the viewer. What are you
going to do, Joe Smith, is classic intimidation.
Oh, this is a this is another I think it misunderstood here and
you'd have to clear that. because you haven't included the part
where that is in response to him saying hang saying if you if
you tried to do this to me I would yeah it's obviously a response
it's obviously about self-defense that is what is being communicated
there very
and any reasonable person would see that
uh by the way I'll just keep reminding people Dan can literally
just click the button on his Discord and join this chat anytime
he likes join this voice call like immediately
I feel like it's important to highlight that cuz he's in chat
right now. He'll probably say I don't have a microphone or something
again.
What does this have to do with Destiny mind? What about Destiny
then?
What do you want about Destiny hater snarker anti-semite?
Well, the the funny thing is he just said something. If Dan had
really been watching the stream enough, okay, he would know we
talk about him on this stream like 10 times more than we talk
about Destiny.
Uh, bite. Unlucky. Okay. Where are we I would rather side with
Dan any day over the
What? I just baffled. I think everyone in this call would also
would also do that.
But you got to give us a crumb of anything that makes sense.
Jason, report that. Report that. J. Jason, report that. Jason,
report that. I'm not gonna, you know, I I don't even want to
make the joke just in case, you know, not not I don't think it
would work. I just don't want to make the joke. Like, I don't
have a Listen, I can't even look at the quote tweets. Okay, Nick,
just unblock. I just want to be able to run my stream normally
from my main account. Okay, what the You can look at them. You
can look at them. Go to the dots in the top right No, I want
to click the button. I don't want to click
or whatever. It's so annoying. Two clicks instead of one click.
So annoying, dude. Anyway, this you get nerd. This is uh Nicholas
Deorio posting pictures of Dan Saltman. This is up. That's That's
really That's PII. That Dan can't stream handle on kick. This
is PII. This PII.
He's directing harassment to Dan's kick channel. That's [__]
up, man. Okay, we'll go into this one. Uh why are you arguing
with me, Lau? I didn't write the law or Twitch to
find an attorney who says you are correct. This is obviously
a contract legal issue and not a feeling issue. Maybe Pisco will
back you up. I'll accept it if he does.
Oh,
is Dan respecting Pisco's uh is he respecting Pisco's legal opinion
today? Are we doing that? That's awesome. Because you're a discourse.
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait.
It's totally bad faith to call somebody a Right.
This is totally This is a disgusting attack. Are we really going
to denigrate the the use of the term rape? Are we really we're
just trivializing the use of the word rape now? Is that okay?
I don't know if that's okay.
Dan is a Dan is a
a discourse. That's just true. Who makes us all look worse by
comparison? This guy is the same guy who's been arguing for for
the whole last year that that anyone who makes a wrong statement
during discussion is
so I mean this guy's been wrong before. I think he's
Dan, you're not even listening to the arguments. We called you
a because Nicholas called you a discourse.
You're not even listening to what? You're not even getting the
jokes. Dan, he said if you're going to call me a this virtue
of destiny, you are as well. JTO,
that wasn't what I was saying. Destiny. Why?
I don't know. I don't know.
God, I
don't just go on call. Dan, this would be such an easy We'd be
so much chiller if we were on call. You're getting hit up because
you're in chat. You're not You're hearing our voice. We're not
hearing each other's voices. We could be having such a more uh
you know,
human conversation if you're on if you're on VC.
We would be much less dehumanizing, Dan, if you were here in
voice. I'm not dehumanizing at all. I I just I just feel like
we're getting, you know, usually we have such a good relationship
with Dan and I I don't feel like it's being properly conveyed
through through text to voice.
Wait, did did Destiny refuse to watch Dan's conversation with
Nick and like take his side? Is that what I'm that what I'm reading
here? Is that what I'm reading? That's that seems to be what
I'm read. Okay, hold on. Okay. Why is it bad faith? So, hold
on. I I have to restart. Nicholas says, "Because you're a discourse
who makes us all look worse by comparison through bad faith attacks
like this one." Why is it bad faith? Dan asks. When should we
substitute our own feelings of what something is versus what
the law says? You're not really engaging with anything in my
post. Just calling me bad faith. I'm not even sure that you dis
what you disagree with. Twitch calls it doxing. California law
calls it doxing.
Well, I think we went through and figured out that like California
law is dubious on whether it is doxing or not. He could go through
the Twitch stuff with chat GPT as well, but I I feel like I don't
know. It seems missing out on the fact that there is no actual
PII that is not made public explicitly by the person involved.
I think that is a critical thing, Dan, that you need to ask those
questions properly and you've omitted it from your
Nick says, "You sent me this screenshot last night. ignored the
words sensitive information and could then you admitted it wasn't
illegal doxing last night live on stream and mostly critique
of Twitch's policy you intentionally misread you have frantically
been trying to find a new position to better fit your fit your
end goal all night clearly um this could include oh yes publishing
confidential infid uh information about a person this could include
social media profiles would be ones that are not explicitly made
almost certainly would be ones not explicitly made public by
the person like you could not get me on doxing either If I put
the link to the profile in my Twitch page and somebody went to
my profile and clicked on it right on their stream. Like that's
you are literally inviting people to do that. There's just no
way.
Anyway, we continue.
Dan responds. Find an attorney who agrees with you. I'll take
chatd agreeing with you so long as it's a fair prompt. Well,
we just did a prompt.
Dan Dan agrees with us now.
Maybe Hassan doxed the random guy who was like sad that Hassan
called him
I I don't think so. I'm pretty confident no. But it it's obvious
he didn't dox the actual chatter, right? Obviously. So, are you
just agreeing that you have no idea what you're talking about
and frantically throwing prompts into a chat GP all night to
try and avoid taking an L? Lol.
Dude, Nick is brutal. What happened to Nick? What did Auggie
do to him? Is was Auggie the Was Auggie like the real Dawn all
along? Is Nick like a a front for a Why am I seeing a map of
all the relationships in your Discord?
Um because people are mentally mentally deranged, mentally unhinged.
Can you pull this up on your stream? I'm so glad that I'm not
on that. No, I'm not pulling it up on my stream.
Kelly, I'm sending Have you seen this, Kelly? I'm sending this
to you. I am explicitly never pulling that up on my stream ever.
I am aware of what you're pointing to there. Yeah. No, I'm good.
I'm good. I'm good.
I am good. Uh, so Dan responds that he has not been just throwing
props in the chat. GBT, no, I am correct and trying to give you
a graceful way out before even more attorneys agree with me.
We are talking about the definition of a word, but you don't
want to rely on attorneys. Instead, you're wrong personal view.
Doxing is mostly based on intent. This is obvious. In the same
way that if I was to send a message to someone on Twitter saying,
"Hey, cool. Yeah. Can you send a pack the package to my sister's
house here? 123 Main Street would not be doxing, but let's destroy
this girl's Sarah's life. She lives at 123 Main Street. Would
you're lost in the sauce. Uh Hassan didn't do that. Hassan didn't
pull this up and go, "Let's destroy this guy's life." Obviously,
why did Dan just keep referring to things that didn't actually
happen? It's just like, why not just analyze the situation as
it is? He's not answering anymore. He could come on voice and
answer if he wanted. He says he's working though. We're not talking
about 123 Main Street. We're talking about a youtube.com/m Oh,
also a good point from Connor here. Yeah, you're a [__]
man. Docs is a broad term and factors matter like intent. That's
the entire point, but you're too smoothrained to understand anything
that involves nuance. Obviously, the Oreo Brigade got to be the
dumbest mofos on the internet. Lol.
Uh, Dan, your people are these people, these like random 70 follower
accounts that like pump you up all over Twitter. They are the
dumbest people in the world. Okay.
Somehow if you put like
Are they calling us the Dioro Brigade?
Do they know who we are? Yeah, they would be calling us the Dioro
Brigade, I guess. Your ass justical blocked and he said all of
the time. Wait, no. No, he's talking about X8. No, he's saying
X8 cuz this gu this's
ex roomate. But I'm saying that we're on this side. We would
be a part of the Deor Brigade
We have a position so we would be
I think you have to be really brain broken to think we have some
kind of positive bias in this situation.
There is none.
Mashup 45, you can join this Discord, okay? Discord.gg/jstlk.
You can join the Discord and if you want to argue that we're
we are wrong, okay? You want to come in and argue, no, you're
wrong, you can do that. You can hop on the stream right now.
hop in the waiting room and I will give you a one-time special
offer. Okay? You get to pick you get to pick who you want to
talk to.
All right? And then the other two people will let you talk to
them for like 5 to 10 minutes. Okay? We will not do any sort
of dog pile on you. Uh no, we don't answer the question, then
you join. You join. Okay? It's Discord or ban. That's the only
way this works. You don't have the power here. We'll just move
on with the content. You can come on the stream if you want and
we can talk and I'll answer your question on the stream or you
can not come on the stream and stay in chat only. Well, you can't
stay in chat only because you're banned already, but
you know that's how it is. Otherwise, just moving on with the
content. Good luck.
Don't know if anyone answered you earlier, but I think Destiny
watched the Dan/nick debate and argued the intent point as well.
Oh, damn. Okay, so Oh, I somebody said I literally don't know.
Somebody just said that he uh watch he refused to watch it and
takes Dan's side or something. Also, I meant to read this chat
because it also is about Dan. Dan said in chat, "Dan said in
chat he won't join because he's friendly with Destiny. He's super
terrified of the Cuban." Yeah, he is scared of Destiny. He can't
be He can't be on here. Okay, that would be really bad.
Isn't Destiny to leak? What happened to
Hawaii. But yes, that was that
Miami. They live in Miami. Of course, they do live in Miami.
Yes. Why? Why?
Uh, this argument is Twitch bans for non-legal doxing. So, I
don't understand why the we're arguing over legal. Uh, because
Dan is arguing that it violates California statute AB1979.
That is the argument. You just haven't identified it. Karate
Moses, that's unlucky for you, but it's okay because we love
you anyway. Okay.
When people say refuse watch, I don't. Okay. Yeah, it's fine,
Hunter. It's not a big deal. Okay. All right. We have more. By
the way, there's just like so much more that happened on Twitter.
I believe we go from this to
I believe we go from this to the O recap, which Dan himself replies
to. Okay. Ox says, "Dan Saltman, Nicholas Dioro have been going
back and forth all day. Disagreement stems from Assange's crash
out on a chatter. You make us all look worth by comparison through
bad va." Actually, that's not what Nick said. Why didn't he put
it? Why didn't he put the full quote in here? O, what are you
doing? How you not going to say that he called Dude, the tweet
goes way harder if you say he called Dan a
Uh, Karate Moses, I believe. Also, under Twitch's toos, this
is not a guaranteed violation in any way. I don't believe it's
a guaranteed violation Twitch to at Like, Twitch's to literally
leaves it open conditionally. Uh, these things may be PII. These
could be PII.
Anyway, why is it bad faith? Find an attorney who agrees with
you. I'm correct. Dan,
where's the Dan response? Where is it? Where is it? Oh, I'm not
going to get Dan's response like pushed to the top of my feed
anymore because he
said I don't follow anymore. Oh, wait. No, hold on. This No.
God damn it. Let me Let me go and find the Dan one. Oh, here
it is. Oh, it's at the bottom of a chain. I see. I got blocked
by Nick for saying that their argument is stupid and to f the
focus should be on what Hassan did rather than the definition
of a word. Yeah, he blocked me on Twitter and Discord, lol. He
been watching Hassan and Jas too much. Slight disagreement. Blocked.
Exiled. I'm right. You're wrong. Jesus Christ, man. When you
go on a winning streak for so long, that one L is going to make
you crash hard. These people are out of their minds. Okay.
Dan Dan says these are the normies, by the way, that agree with
him. And I'm like, okay, I I'm sorry. Trump technically gets
like 48% of the popular vote or 49% of the popular vote. Okay.
Just because the normies agree with you doesn't doesn't necessarily
mean anything. Okay,
sorry boys. He kicked me from his Discord if it makes you feel
better. I'll wait for legal mindset to clarify. Not much more
to say until then. Also, I don't know why he's ad homing as I
thought we were chill, but I felt it last night, so I redacted
our DMs. Sucks, but better now versus later.
This gets quote tweeted by our boy.
Our ascended for formerly fallen ascended commentary YouTuber
Nicholas Dioro. Auggie has revived him. Okay. Wait, why would
I not kick you from the Discord? You reacted all our messages
preemptively because you had a bad debate performance. Lol. Uh,
I don't I actually don't know why that means you would get kicked
from the Discord. I That statement in a vacuum makes no sense
to me whatsoever.
Um,
I Well, I mean, I assume he's just like that they're both I think
what he's saying is that they're both clearly like Dan is displaying
that either he thinks Nick is about to completely him over or
that Dan is getting ready to completely Nick over. So Nick's
saying that it's like, "Okay, well, you're getting gone from
my because you're acting mad sketchy right now." Dan deletes
his DMs with me all the Yeah. And he's probably thinking about
you over. It's pretty much when we get in a disagreement, the
DM's going to members only Discord. Dan should have paid. O,
luckily I did this when JC is exploding his life. Hey, you know
this is the cycle of uh all things on the internet, okay? Somebody
up, somebody destroys their and then the next person does it,
you cover that. Okay, it is what it is.
I think a lot of people have vested interest for some reason
in making
this into something it wasn't. Okay, explo. This is a little
hyperbolic from Dan here. Okay. Not Nicholas. Nicholas is quoting
him. So, this is what spicy. I can't even tell what this is.
Discord maybe. I think it's Nick. Oh, this is Nick's Discord.
Oh, I see. I regret nothing. And luckily, I did this when Jay-Z
talk is exploding his life. Oh, Dan tried to Dan saw Nick do
it so many times. Okay. You know, you take the path of least
least resistance. Hey, don't we all hate this guy? We all hate
this guy. [__] J. Am I right, guys? Am I right?
He was he was you know if he'd had one one more L held on stream
he would have just been like guys can we ask Kelly Jean's opinion
on this guys what does Kelly Jean think about this I'll call
do you not know Kelly crazy when D was being spicy earlier being
like uh you know the worst part about Mr. girl is. He was so
ineffective. So, okay. All right. Okay,
That's I guess it's one take as Destiny's best friend. Well,
Dan really Hold on. Dan Dan really enjoyed that Cuties review.
Okay, he just really liked it. This is the worst part is clearly
that he was ineffective. The cuties review.
Sorry, did I miss something? Why am I thought you were just implying
that my opinion is like the saddest option to go to? Did I get
that right? No, it's that wasn't it. Uh you you just missed it.
I was kind of mocking the idea that like Nicholas will do this
sometimes. He'll go like when he doesn't really have a point,
he'll go like, "Let's ask Kelly Jean for her opinion on this,
right?" Cuz he doesn't have something actually to say.
That's all. I was just making fun of that. I was like
from doing that to me for sure. It's okay. It wasn't us making
fun of you, Kelly. Promise. Ro wants to to fake ego cope after
you got reamed live. I do a weekly show. I don't think you know
me. It's a regular show.
I don't It's a regular show. Okay. I don't care what shows you
do. I still think you got owned. I don't care.
And Nick. Nick going hard on this guy. Nick. Nick Nick just decided
he was going to try to kill That Dan is the crash out king. Okay.
It can't be denied. This This guy is the crash out king. He will
take an L and just absolutely drive it into the dirt. He used
to have people protecting him. Okay. I used to be like, remember
when we used to do this for Dan? We'd be like, "Dan, you can't
say that. Dan, you got to be chill. Dan, you're crashing
Dan, you're crashing out right now. Dan, stop crashing out. We
used to help this guy. It sucks when their ego gets too big and
then they can't take advice from their dear, dear friends. And
they leave. They leave. Dan, you got the freaks in here siding
with Big Nick. Shows you up real bad. They hate dreams. No way.
This isn't a real message. He did not say this. There's no chance
he said this. This is a fake message. There's He cannot do I'm
sure he said that. I'm certain he said that.
I didn't say it, but I'm certain it
That is crazy. Look, if Dan were to join, he could be on the
stream. Look, we got a Dan avatar somebody got ready for if he
joins. Look, it could be Kitty Cat Dan on the stream right now.
Unlucky. Unlucky. Okay.
All right.
So, we had the whole thing with Nick and uh Dan going back and
forth. I think there's still more stuff going on here. Where
is this one? This in the uh
bottom of this guy. Yeah, the bottom of this guy.
Oh, I I actually dropped it out. Anyway, I'll figure out where
we're going. Oh, we went to the Nick quote tweet, right? I believe
we went to the Nick quote tweet. Yes. Why would I not kick you
from the Discord? Then he does this stuff. I think there were
new replies from them, weren't there? Hold on. Let me Let me
go see if I have more here to go over. There is definitely more
here that I'm going to go over. Just look cuz I or Hold on. We
can watch this Chud clip again as well. I asked why did Dan burn
the Deoro Bridge. He says I didn't. He went insane. He's responding
to every random post on Twitter and he kicked me from his Discord.
I think it's done. Boy. Oh boy.
Argument on Twitter. Go read it. I don't even know. I was just
looking at his I was looking at his posts in Spicy and grabbing
them before he uh before he deleted them, which he did pretty
quickly. But he claims that Nicholas is the one who went insane.
I don't think Nicholas went insane. I think Nicholas, you know,
Nicholas, Nicholas is just right here. Yeah, he's just right.
And it's like, dude, Nicholas is literally Nicholas is literally
dealing with like or sorry, my my opinion of Nichol I hate Nicholas,
bro. No, I don't. I don't actually hate him. Although, he's he's
like uh something I don't like.
Oh, you know, I just I've just received I'm receiving reporting
JTO. I'm just receiving very crazy reporting coming in. Nicholas
Dorio currently saying in his Discord, "Are there any archives
of Dan Sman's Twitch streams about the Twitch apocalypse?"
Someone says, "You watched the whole thing on stream or close,
didn't you?" He says, "Not on stream. No, I watched offline.
Maybe JTO did. I have to ask him." Uh, that's what Nick's saying
right now. Oh, based. Um,
do I have
definitely got some clips archived?
I don't know. I don't know. I I don't even listen, Nick. From
what I understand, Nick kept his commentary. Nick's looking Is
Nick looking for a specific clip? Is he looking for the one about
families going off people's
Nick says, "I hate everyone who has the clip and I bet they are
too stupid to know they have it except JT Stalk." Do you think
that's he's talking about? We're literally fine. I think like
Nicholas's coverage of this of my stuff was just like, "Oh, this
looks really bad optically.
This guy sucks and I'm going to laugh at him." which, you know,
I I have a hard time fighting against any of those things. So,
realistically, as long as he's not doing weird like trying to
sane Destiny, we're fine.
you'll be able to find them, Nick. Either way, I don't know.
I don't know if he's watching or not.
I That actually just reminded me of mine and Nick's conversations
on that. Very interesting.
Yeah. Wait, do you have that clip? He's He's actually just messaging
me. Oh, which one? What clip do you have? The one about the one
about getting people's Facebooks and all that [__]
I mean, I've got it on my laptop. I've got it on my laptop if
he wants it. It take me a second to go find it, though. Can you
just mention Can you just be like, "Hey, you don't have to follow
me. Just unblock me on Twitter so I'm not Does anyone have that
to hand? Does anyone have that clip to hand of going crazy about
Trust and Safety's Facebook Hold on. I'll just go grab it off
my laptop. Give me two seconds. I shouldn't do that, actually.
Hold on.
Do I not have this here? Hold on. I'm looking. I'm looking. Give
me a second, guys. What is this? Oh, yeah. Uh,
this one. Hold on. I'm finding it, guys. Give me two seconds.
So, Kelly, what do you think of the map of all the relationships
in JS Discord? Take a look at that. Absolutely. [__]
Um, I mean, to be fair, some of these
Discord, like a lot of these don't have anything to do with this
Discord. It's just kind of funny. Yeah, it's more like connection,
isn't it? Sure. If you were to assume it all related to Discord.
Yeah. Most of it's just people destiny
plus
some stuff that had nothing to do with this discord. Like Abby,
where's Legacy? That stuff doesn't have anything to do with here,
right? It's just like why is Cena connected to Artful? Please.
Is she he dating another person? Surely not. I have no idea.
That must be some of these must just be memes. I don't know.
You see, there's uh some other stuff that goes along with this.
Where are we going? Okay.
Trying to figure out I got sent some stuff midstream.
What is this stuff? Oh, these are just random. Okay. These are
just random tweets going along. Okay. All right. Docs that poor
man. Why are people shamelessly sharing his face information
around without blurring it? That's true. That's happening.
We quote tweeted Dan says obvious provable lies. Twitch cos states
that doxing is the use of confidential information. Nicholas
retweeted him by the way. Wow.
Yeah, Nick. Uh, just accept the friend request on Discord. Okay.
I will send you that clip promptly. I got it. I don't know if
he's watching. I don't know if he's watching. I mean, he literally
just asked me in Oh. Oh, is he?
I don't think that's the real person. Is
Uh, it is.
I think VIPed. Yeah, he's VIPed. Oh, that's him. Sorry, John.
Or just make it join a mutual discord server. Rejoin spicy. Rejoin
and not talk about your BMI. Come back to a hero's welcome, Nicholas.
I can't send you a message. I'm like trying to send this to you
right now.
Anyway, okay.
Boom. There it is. Right there. You got it. Good luck. I'm pretty
sure that's it. If that's not it, I've got it. I've got it. I
just um I had like a couple.
Okay. All right. Let's continue on.
Let's continue on.
What was this? I like Legal Mindset, by the way, but I have a
hard time understanding why he would imply showing someone's
public YouTube channel would be illegal doxing. Illegally doxing
in any jurisdiction that matters. Uh
oh. It's going to be uh it's going to be rough when they look
at a lot of the other legal analysis. Uh this is good stuff.
This is good stuff. Okay. That's all of the Nicholas stuff. Okay.
All right. And then something else we had.
Latest post, latest replies. Oh, this is like Nicholas's latest
stuff. Got it.
Commentary. Holy War is on hold. If they do a show tomorrow,
do the show tomorrow is scheduled. It's going to be insane.
Oh, like anything else? Oh, Nick. No, no. The Willian the Willian
Willian Dan thing. Yeah. I think uh I think Oh boy. I don't know
how you get that going. Sorry. I don't even think we're going
to cover it unless it's like uh actually funny. I feel like it's
going to be boring. Both these people like I mean I I love Dan.
I love Dan and he's not quite like Willie, but they're both kind
of like border
and I can't imagine it being a good a good
Cam the jelly man thing for the 11 months. Yeah. I think the
good part about Dan is like how he reacts when you tell him he's
wrong about something and Exactly. Yes. Yeah. Will he doesn't
do Yeah.
Unlucky. See here. Just look. I'm just looking through for uh
Nicholas's stuff here. Oh, right. There's the Copen Seth tweet
as well, which actually leads into another thing that that actually
segus real nicely. I like that. Okay. Also, this seems like an
insane thing for Dan to even argue about considering that Destiny
has called for people's doxes multiple times. I don't even mean
recently. Remember that [__] with the girl who threatened
to egg him on his university tour? Dan/DG sweep this
They sweep it constantly.
Dan doesn't have to crash. He can just come on the stream. What
is the weird queen crying Quigler? What is this? Oof.
It's fine with me. People are trying to get him to watch the
stream. All right. All right. You are getting beyond hung up
on him redacting his messages as if there is some obligation
for him to keep them given the conversation. That's just not
the case. Even if you feel it's bad faith, you're getting hung
up on willfully ignoring the context and sucking his oof.
Oof. All right.